è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj grazie a dio oggi sono
con thomas se no avrei sucato che la
metà basta siamo su darwin project che è
un gioco che dovrebbe somigliare a forno
e che almeno quanto mi dice thomas
minecraft forma e dovrebbe essere tipo
forte in cui sapete infornati sono
fortissimo quindi anche qui non ci sono
problemi adesso scegliere forma destra
freddie mercury e quindi tu hai l'arco e
lascia sì allora destro esponiamo
davanti a due alberi del team va bene
list per accettarlo io prendo l'altro
lasciate questa l'albero andata tenendo
premuto destro l'anci le frecce l'unico
problema che non le abbiamo sa bene
aveva perfetto vedere come le primarie
devono crollare la legna si tiene
premuto cupo farlo già adesso si è
evoluto clic sulla freccia e collegno
aka stile fra che storia io sono delle
poltrone in giro eccole lì ti danno un
altro materiale per farmi guardare
questa luce bianca è uno degli oggetti
rari del gioco vieni su quello puoi
raccogliere
lo stesso costa strani chiamo sto
vedendo si sblocca l'abilità e al terzo
oggetto cioè legno il la stoffa del
poltrone questo vai sulla carta della
verità quella che vince di più che come
si sa che così barriera e poi ce l'ha
per tutta la partita dopo che le
sbloccata poi ci sono solo dieci persone
nel server quindi siamo noi e altri rom
siamo solo i miei persone celine cento
c'è anche questa è una cosa [ __ ] gli
tira un colpo addio
porca vacca diretta marcia delle sue
volate come fifa e la madonna mikati
sono caduti in testa preciso non stanno
arrivando qua perché a chiamare forte
stanno arrivando che è successa sopra la
montagnetta qua ecco come ha sparato a
sia una visibile cerca vacca usati pure
la barriera se sei sempre stato un vero
peccato è presa 12 volt è bravino ci
sono entrambi grande non l'ha ucciso
l'ho ucciso no no no no no sono ancora
vivi entrambi
e ora che puoi correre come un matto da
sarebbe quando praticamente a segno il
colpo
dov'è la gente non viene qua e qua preso
da che è quasi morto quali ora chiama
collocato nell home port kakà dove sono
mi hanno ucciso
sono entrando nelle pochissime vita dai
che ce la fai no va bene iaia c'è anche
la biglietteria nomi le frecce corri in
fatto ma non riesco a colpirlo mai
ninja ninja ragazzi abbia messo un sacco
di colpi la prima per i bimbi abela
prima la prima ora andiamo
bye bye bye partiamo vedo un albero
tagliato una poltrona da tagliare
ci sono dei passi lì per terra se
qualcuno che appena passata velocemente
qua c'è gente così dente che stanno
attaccando in seguito ho preso uno da da
casey che ce li facciamo lo aspetta uno
l'ho beccato lascia dovrebbe funzionare
sarà con delle ferite provare sul che
porta gli ha dato aspetta resistere ed
ai e ci sono sono contento l'ho ucciso
c'è l'altro ce l'ha ucciso con un
giovane re continua a correre c'è il
bonus del semiti le frecce se il bonus e
non le frecce
porca vacca menaye mela ieri mereilles e
non ho mica quanto dura stupito ma come
ti diranno se lo prenda lasciano le
frecce ma è quasi morto
se metti nato un colpo me grazie cioè
poi posso colpirti ad esse ti colpiscono
no non mi faccio male
metto il cam farvi vediamoci proprio
loro i guerrieri che bravi siamo stati
bravissimi puoi farli la cura messa a
meno di matino fatta già fatta ok è già
fatta guardale già è preparatissima
prezzo da forse vanno a via ragazzi
aspetta con the flash 7 bene dai dai dai
dai
così si diano senso che altro che inizia
quasi agente passo prata che guardo
investigo diamo sarà invece di investire
oh cavolo
cos'è successo della zona ma torniamo
indietro devono uscire sono fuori dalla
zona porca vacca preso arrivano due
volte
porca
aspetta uno lo ha colpito da perfetto
fatto porca eva grande yacht però non
vedo più niente c'è una fumogena se la
vista
maledizione chi 6 conti 6 consiglio che
stanno dietro i da besson
porca vacca uno di loro sul mercato
pochissima vita ok spettacolo vedo uno
eccolo qua e visibilità di me l'ha visto
si sta seguendo un grande mamma mi ha
preso bravissimo preso ancora era che
attenzione a usare una sopra se non per
una sopra abbiamo il bel gran ucciso
mamma mia mi prendo questo grande ne
mancano due gare siamo due contro due è
meglio le frecce le frecce non lei non
le ho raccolte quando le spara ora è
importante i consigli e le rughe 0
frecce comunque rifatti l'armatura ha
subito porca vacca perché me l'hanno
rotta proprio perche non trovare una
casa scoprire dove sono gli ultimi due e
prima oltre freccia aspetta non puoi
passarle ma se sei se 6 furbo fai così
le spari per terra esatto
grazie grazie amico perfetta e 98 da una
catena ebbene abbiamo visto negli
avversari perché piazza una trappola si
fa allora ci sta io l'ho piazzato ma si
vede ma richiama quanto si vede non si
vende non si sa quanto si vede mai prova
ci domandiamo electronics tra
sull'elettronica ne ho preso uno l'ho
preso fra l'altro bravissimo
o che la torretta distrutta non li vedo
dove sarà un sapore che te l'abilità
tranquillo riparati che l'abbiamo
l'ultimo combattimento 1 e quella porta
ha preso preso ancora uno e morto e
l'altro aiuto di test ok
l'ho capito tutto la barriera ok altre
morto ma vediamo vediamo se sotto cui la
vediamo a prendere vediamo allora
chiamato nakata raccolgono le frecce 3
su tende eccolo è stato fighissimo ora
che belli che si sa quanto casato 6 10 6
swat
non vorrei dire la mia anche anche
strameritata direi può fare l'ultima si
l'ultima dai ci sta l'ultima si parte
prende quest'albero si vola ho mai
sparato quest'anno tutto amava la prendo
prendilo ora cavalca la lava
tutte quante allora ti dico che abbiamo
vicino c'è gente che sta arrivando te lo
do re mi sa che un fuori scala volare ok
stai molto attento e io ho una sola
freccia e facciamo schifo in questo
momento è il sì esattamente
rimani fermo aspetta che arrivino sul
costo e li prendiamo eccoli li vedo se
sono qua vicino
se arriva arrivando arrivando uno l'ho
beccato land ho visto visto ci sia il
berserk aggressivissimo arrivo anch'io
lo vedo più ovvio che ritira nella lava
se ti prendono le sei un pazzo
eccoli preso bravissimo ha preso un
tronco rav ore un figlio del grande non
è morto arrivari motivo di bar
scavalcati da me non ci sono a volte è
morto e l'altro raccogliete le frecce e
veloce che l'altro salivano romperà sono
messa abbastanza bene ora arrivo da
tempo oggi sono qua direi molto bene
ragazzi ma giocando con qualcuno porca
vacca risi che male quasi e non
arrivando ai armi attivato la freccia
c'è la militanza che pato
ok per farlo se sono contesto al
contempo siamo un po i colori ma dai che
ce la facciamo
dov'è pertanto leggo tra la natura
l'ho preso e qui l'altro prendiamo sto
frizzante maledizione non vedo niente
cioè tutto il ghiaccio porca vacca lo
uno è morto un è morto un è morta siamo
due contro uno e adesso vai dai dai dai
dai dai
poi è andato preso sono morti sono
partiti ancora voti prego fai fosse
morto come no però grande rovesciata
sempre la combo è fatto da poco
incredibile l'area è morto morto è morto
grande ce l'abbiamo fatta
vai vai ti prego che il fuoco muoio fi
fuoco muoio
arrivo fini sottolineo cross di rizzato
venisse lo sta facendo
salta giù saltano ti prego ho fatto io
mi ha spaventato un sacco o mio dio devo
trovare madonna c'è niente di vita però
puoi sparare alle alle renne ti danno 50
di vita ognuna accennarci carcere perche
volo siete no si gente si sente se gli
ultimi due
ma di fronte non li vedo neanche partita
dell'arena usa e qui è che io sono
contro un altro invece siamo uno contro
uno
le frecce si schiantano sul loro a non
fosse uno io dentro anche sono da solo
però iniziano adesso per niente franchi
tranche tre che sono qua sta resistendo
ha tolto l'armatura entrambi bravo lo 1
capitolo 1 grande preso anche l'altro
anche norma non frecce ok dai che sono
gli ultimi due mi sa si ok è quando
mario uno è morto
tra gli ultimi erano gli ultimi da vero
capitano gli ultimi stadi si è negli
utili a caso non ho mica capito io che
pirla e ne vincono un'altra proprio no
signori e al mentre l'altro gioco nostro
spero che vi sia piaciuto ringrazio
thomas bravi fatto ad accompagnatori in
questa avventura incredibile ne faremo
sicuramente altre semplice un botto
bella anche la mente fighissimo ai
ragazzi spray vi sia piaciuto come se si
riduce con te mi piace anche socialmente
iniziali sono sentiti chiedere
[Musica]